il sera finalement le seul yvelinois en
lice pour la primaire de la droite et du
centre les 20 et 27 novembre prochains
jean frédéric poisson bénéficie d'un
statut particulier dans cette campagne
en qualité de président du parti
chrétien démocrate
ils n'étaient pas soumis à l'obstacle
des parrainages une aubaine pour
l'ancien maire de rambouillet déjà en
campagne depuis plusieurs mois nécessité
dans la mesure où je n'ai pas trouvé de
candidat qui défendent une vision proche
de la mienne si cette candidature
est soutenue pendant dix huit ans de
ramener l'économie partage favorable de
la france dans l'europe
favorables à un règlement international
national
et encore une fois on fait d'affirmer
j'ai une vraie différence à l'égard
d'autres en temps je suis seule la
partie c'est différent
effectivement
lui n'avait que peu d'espoirs de réunir
les parrainages nécessaires pour le
souverainiste jacques myard député-maire
de maisons-laffitte
l'essentiel était ailleurs pour faire un
candidat à la présidence de la
république ou même un président de la
république on ne se lève pas le matin
je dirais simon avant dix ans je vais y
aller tout ça fait
donc imprimé cancer mais j'ai atteint
mon objectif
c'est d'être dans le pré débat
pour m'exprimer sur les thèses qui sont
les miennes à savoir le rétablissement
la souveraineté de la france henri
guaino parlait d' escroquerie
démocratique pour évoquer la primaire
l'ancienne plume de nicolas sarkozy a
échoué lui aussi à rassembler les
parrainages suffisants sur sa
candidature et a donc décidé de se
présenter seul à l'élection
présidentielle le député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines qui n'a pas
donné suite à nos demandes d'interview
devra désormais relever un autre
challenge obtenir le soutien de 500 élus
locaux pour espérer devenir président de
la république